on this wednesday checkup i want to talk
about the two urgent care doctors that
are making headlines for their
controversial statements regarding covet
19.
this all started on april 22nd when two
doctors dan erickson and art masihi
called a press conference to discuss
their thoughts on covet 19 and the
reopening of america based on the 5 000
patients they tested in their urgent
care centers the main takeaways from the
press conference are as follows one the
government is horribly mishandling the
situation by ignoring the science and
only focusing on controlling the public
two way more people are sick with covet
19 than is currently reported three the
fatality rate of coven 19 is much lower
than currently being reported and it's
similar to the flu and finally four that
america should reopen now because the
harms of keeping it closed much outweigh
the benefits in the days following their
press conference they received
nationwide attention mostly because
their recommendations and opinions were
in stark contrast with the medical
community and the cdc also the video of
the press conference became increasingly
popular on social media where it picked
up over 5 million views on youtube and
it received retweets from popular
figures like elon musk who supported the
doctors fast forward to april 27th and
youtube has now taken the video down
stating that it's broken community
guidelines basically saying that there's
a lot of misinformation in it and
there's been a joint statement released
by the american college of emergency
physicians and the american academy of
emergency medicine let me read that
statement the aecp and aaem jointly and
emphatically condemned the recent
opinions released by dr erickson and dr
masini these reckless and untested
musings do not speak for medical
societies and are inconsistent with
current science and epidemiology
regarding covid19 as owners of local
urgent care clinics it appears these two
individuals are releasing biased
non-peer-reviewed data to advance their
personal financial interests without
regard for the public's health i
completely agree with these statements
because these individuals presented so
much misinformation that it's further
gonna confuse the general public let me
explain why the information these
doctors presented is just not
scientifically accurate look the fact
that they tested 5 000 patients in their
urgent care centers and 6 of them tested
positive for covet 19 makes a lot of
sense and it's actually probably
accurate but what's not accurate and
what does it make sense is to then take
six percent that number and assume that
if you test all of new york state or all
of california then six percent of those
people will also test positive that's
just not how statistics work the people
that go to an urgent care center are
more likely to test positive because
they're showing symptoms because they
likely had exposure to covid19 that's
why they're there in general when you're
testing a pre-selected population like
that you're going to have higher numbers
it's like assuming that if you go to
southern california and gather the
weather data you can then extrapolate it
and assume that the weather is the same
in new york and then with the incorrect
assumption that six percent of the
general public must be coveted positive
they go on to calculate a fatality rate
that's similar to the flu let me go
ahead and explain to you how we
calculate a death rate so it all makes
sense first we take all the people
who've died with covet 19 and we divide
that number by all the people who've
been infected with covet 19. let's run
an example here if 10 people have died
of covet 19 and a thousand have been
infected you divide ten by a thousand
and you get one percent it makes a one
percent death rate now if you
incorrectly assume that way more people
have had covet 19 than is true you can
artificially lower this death rate my
second issue is let's go ahead and
assume their calculations are correct
they're not it doesn't change the fact
that covet 19 is still much more
dangerous than the flu reason being that
covet 19 spreads at a two to three times
faster rate than the flu which means
that it can overwhelm our hospital
systems in the blink of an eye in fact
that's what the purpose of all these
lockdowns were to ease the strain on our
hospital systems so we can continue
taking care of patients that are not
only suffering with covin but with all
the other medical elements out there if
you would have been in a car accident
there would be no one to help you if you
called for a heart attack there would
have been no one to help you we must
also remember that for the flu we have a
vaccine we have an fda approved
treatment so by maintaining the lockdown
for a slightly longer period of time
we're buying time in order to get there
to get the vaccine and to get the
treatments authorized these are all the
reasons why i've been consistently
saying on my youtube channel to my
patients on television that while covet
19 looks similar to the flu to virus
upper respiratory symptoms they are not
the same they are fundamentally
different in that covid19 spread so
quickly and puts such a tremendous
strain on our healthcare system that it
can break it in fact i'd love for these
emergency medicine physicians who are no
longer working in emergency rooms to
come to new york city and talk to the er
doctors that are working on the front
lines to see how overwhelmed they were
with this apparently mild virus during
its peak let's move on to the topic of
reopening america these individuals are
adamant about reopening america right
now because they're talking about the
negative consequences that are happening
as a result of this lockdown social
issues like domestic violence and child
abuse patients not being able to get
care because they're worried about
getting sick with kovid routine
procedures being rescheduled economic
harms all of these negative consequences
are very true and we need to take them
into consideration when we're weighing
the benefits versus harms of a lockdown
the last thing we want to do is to rush
to reopen america haphazardly and see a
spike in the resurgence of covid19 cases
possibly destroying our healthcare
system potentially putting thousands if
not millions of lives at risk because
they might not be able to get care at a
hospital look we absolutely need to
start taking steps in reopening america
if we continue this for much longer
there's going to be limited benefit and
more harms being added on but the way we
do this is strategically we open certain
areas first and we continuously gather
information to see what impact we're
having on covet 19 numbers and then use
that data to gradually reopen the
country slowly carefully and most
importantly safely at the end of the day
no one benefits from keeping america
closed in fact this whole theory of
politicians keeping america closed just
to keep control over the general public
is nonsensical they're getting hurt by
this too and so are their families if
you're going to be a public-facing
medical professional that goes on to
talk about covid19 and say that you're
talking about science at least do it
accurately and keep the politics out of
it these doctors aren't the first to be
spreading misinformation about covid19
so are politicians and so is the media
click here for those videos and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you